Libs of tick tock for instance by simply  tweeting out I'm sorry retweeting videos  posted by people publicly  she's murdering them so there's this  viral to I comment on it where they're  like you know uh uh Libs of tick tock  has murdered hundreds of LGBT people by  sharing these videos and it's like bro  the videos are public right literature  isn't doing anything if that's their  standard and people have to abide by  those kind of psychotic individuals  they're scared to speak out now Elon  comes in and says have fun guys and what  are we seeing spicy memes jokes trolling  and fun yeah comedy and you know what  Jack White well he doesn't like fun he  says fun is bad so he has to leave okay  bye-bye we'll play your music dude I  don't care we'll we'll have we'll have  fun and and post spicy memes  bring back the meme Wars